President Trump says he is going to
follow through on his threat to suspend
funding to the World Health Organization
in the middle of this pandemic the
president says the money will be
withheld pending an investigation as
criticism has swirled around his own
administration's handling of the crisis
he has suggested that the w-h-o should
have done more to warn the United States
had the w-h-o done its job to get
medical experts into China to
objectively assess the situation on the
ground and to call out China's lack of
transparency the outbreak could have
been contained at its source
with very little death the u.s. gave the
geneva-based organization more than 450
million dollars last year that's
according to the Associated Press
the group's mission is to fight diseases
ensure patients get health care they
need and prevent outbreaks Anthony
joining us now from Washington is the
director of the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention dr. Robert
Redfield dr. Redford field good morning
and thank you for being with us thanks
for having me Anthony I want to get to
the president's decision about cutting
funding for the w-h-o in a moment but I
want to start with this framework for
reopening the country which the
Washington Post reports that the CDC and
FEMA have been working on for the past
week that involves the lifting of all
mitigation over a period of a hundred
and eighty days how long before this
report is finalized and what guidance
exactly have you been giving the
president well CDC has been involved
from the beginning in giving both
science and data to help advise policies
on this outbreak response and obviously
I'm an active member of the White House
Task Force we continue CDC to provide
our perspectives in terms of being
consideration as the task force as a
group is looking at all the different
options for our plan to begin to help
assist the states as they begin to
reopen our country where we're poised to
provide assistance it's going to be
really
important to get a few things in place
more obviously testing for early
diagnostics expand the public health
capacity for early diagnosis isolation
and contact tracing this is going to be
fundamental to maintain and contain
cases as they occur and then make sure
we have the health capacity to deal with
this as we work to regain the confidence
in the American public that it's safe to
go back to work how do you see that
process working out your predecessor
doctor Tom one of your predecessors dr.
Tom Frieden
has said in terms of contact tracing we
could need a essentially an army of
health care workers as big as 300,000
people we're obviously nowhere close to
that we're also behind in testing how
long before we're ready to begin this
process well I think we're continuing to
improve the availability of testing
every day at the level of the States and
that's going to continue
I think expanding the public health
workforce so that we have more
individuals boots on the ground in the
field so that when cases identified you
can do very rapid comprehensive contact
tracing we're in the process of
augmenting that we've also provided
substantial resources to the states so
they're going to begin to augment that
capacity and I think we'll have a
collective expansion of boots on the
ground ultimately what the ultimate
number is that's going to be required I
think is still speculative but we're
prepared to move that forward and
improve that you know local public
health capacity so people are diagnosed
rapidly and when they are they're
isolated and the contacts are traced and
then they're diagnosed and then they're
they're isolated and then our contacts
are traced that's going to be
fundamental this outbreak got beyond
containment this time we need to get it
back so the containments an important
part of our overall strategy that then
will be supported by some targeted
mitigation there is one study that's
reporting that we not may not be able to
ease social distancing if we don't get a
vaccine until 2022
do you see that being a possibility I
think mitigation staffs steps that we've
done are going to be an important
component of it
I think it's really really a moment to
take a bow for the American public that
really embraced the social distancing
recommendations that we put forward I
think when you saw the original models
that I had to see from CDC that modeled
up to 2.2 million people dying before
the fall you know it was potentially
catastrophic as you can see obviously
the 26,000 lives lost is 26,000 too many
but that said it really is the American
public's response to social distance and
sacrifice not for themselves but for the
benefit of the most vulnerable it's
really a testament I do think we're
going to have some social distancing
that's going to be in a critical part of
our strategy as we go forward while we
await the fruits of the innovation of
the different biological countermeasures
to include a vaccine on the topic of the
World Health Organization and the
president cutting off funding Bill Gates
said overnight in his words that that is
as dangerous as it sounds you've called
the whu-oh a an important partner do you
view cutting off funding to them as
dangerous you know I just going to say
that w-h-o has been and a long-standing
partner for CDC we've worked together
and to fight health crisis all around
the world we continue to do that we're
working side by side now in the Congo
and in the DRC with trying to bring the
Ebola outbreak to an end we're working
obviously together on this coronavirus I
think it's important at this point that
we leave the analysis of what could have
been done better and what what what what
maybe we did well - once we get through
this and get through the the outbreak we
get it over and then dr. Redfield if if
you cut off funding if you cut off
funding to the w-h-o and this is a
significant amount of their funding in
the middle of a pandemic what's the
impact internationally to fighting this
virus again I'm going to come back to
w-h-o has been a long-term and still as
a great partner for us we're going to
continue to do all we can together to
try to limit this those decisions that
are going to be made of
related to some of the geopolitical
issues I have to leave to those that
really have that expertise but for me
and for CDC and the public health arena
we're continuing to work side by side
with w-h-o to do the best that we can to
limit the spread of disease and to
protect the American people all right
dr. Redfield that's not really telling
me how much damage you think this is
going to do but thank you very much